We're leaving for guys have command
Command of themselves commanded their minds commander the ball and ultimately the command of their team
You find those guys you pour your life into you pour the resources of people have spent [a] lifetime
coaching playing this position and
What you've learned is now the have better command of their future teams or college teams or pro teams and will extend that influence
To all the people that they have influence over
That's the beauty of the lila
We hear it. We say it. We believe it, but can we see the it factor
The games online you can see in a person's eyes. It's noticeable
[if] great competitors find a way
The effector, you can call it swagger
Called preparation, I'm gonna call hard work, and I'ma call. It consistency. They make the players around them better
the effector welcome to the in Factory
How many have ever heard of the Phrase the it factor?
There's the most undefinable phrase in the history of sports and performance sometimes you can see it [b]. Can't describe it our staff
We're looking for those undefinable traits all the intangible elements. We will be evaluating. Yes. This is a quarterback competition
We are looking for the not just they 11 best quarterback the top
Competitors in the entire country that 11 out of the last 13 Heisman trophy winners have been elite 11 quarterbacks
10 out of the last 13 national
championship teams were quarterback by Elite 11 quarterbacks
All right the last seven guys taken number one quarterbacks taken number one in the draft including golf this year Elite 11 quarterbacks
26 out of 32 starters in the NFL elite 11 quarterbacks
We [traveled] around the country we had 14 different regional camps big major markets are very Los Angeles Dallas, Atlanta, Miami
New York, New Jersey
DC. All over the country every weekend in the Spring February through May
Put your cleats on step out on this football [field] and like I like to tell them hey five stars [three] stars
No stars that doesn't matter to us
we want to see kids with our own eyeballs our goal of the late 11 and
Nike supports us to go around the country and give everyone a chance
I mean with several thousand try to get into a regional workout, but some of them are in fourth grade
And we're not ready for [that]
The Elite 11 does a good job of giving kids more tools in their toolbox?
to get to where they want to be which ultimately is [the] NFL you look at the brand it's
14 First-round [picks] that's I mean there's schools that don't have 14 first-round picks
We [combined] the evaluation of their film. Which is a huge part of it for us it's 50%
25% on what we see your performance at the regional camp and then 25% [as] well in the physical traits so combining all those metrics
That's how we come up with the list of the 24 that come out to join us in Los Angeles for the Elite 11 finals
This is a cam petition [our] camp learning park competition
I want to see who has it
In La it's early season regionals. [I] mean, it's the second regional of the year and some of these guys come and they expect to
Dominate and earn their way right away, but you still got [to] earn it with us. Good job. Good job. Good job
Okay, good. Good. Good. No
shot
[my] experience at the La regionals I came out kind of little nervous [a] little tight
Don't slide through step through I wasn't having falling. I wasn't me out there
Chase Garber's is gonna be my MVP yeah. He kind of came from the bottom and worked his way above Sears
You know he kind of earned his way up there our second is like to the elite 11 finals for Bishop Gorman [tay] Martel
[Jack] is a dude, but that day you didn't have it. I did not invite another
The quarterback [position] is very artistic
And [I] think they Chris Roberson exactly that I consider his play almost abstract art
He's poetry in motion
[when] you look at him creatively, that's how his mind
Operates and have you ever been around an artist when they get into their flow when they get another zone?
No one can touch them. I'm getting invited today
He's got a juice about him that not too many other guys in this class do
I step on this video. I
Shot my man so I came out the [wound] to compete
He is different
He's not a hundred percent
Football like all these guys he has a lot of interests you had three people dead or alive to go to dinner with tonight who?
Would they be Elton John John Lennon hate not?
Asking the quarterbacks unconventional questions. It's just another way to gauge their personality another way to gauge
What do they prioritize in their life? How many instruments you put come on for the musicians? You just named yeah, but I just
said I listen to music like
24/7 every Year we have a kid that
Beats the tune of Their own drum
[Chris] is that kid
Butterflies, it's what I feed inside
My other side it's a little goofy. [I] just like to have fun
I'm good [with] what makes a quarterback great is we have conviction with who you are that I'm comfortable being
Me [I] think Chris fits into that he will be at his best when people let him be his eccentric self
BP mesquite [or] Chris Robeson
Good job buddy. Nice work. We're all good quarterbacks, but I feel like I'm the best in the nation
some kids that come out to the regionals and have nerves or they're they're looking around and worrying about what other guys are [doing] and
How they're throwing when we saw Davis mills at the Charlotte regional the regional for him was just another workout. [oh]
He can throw
I'm trying to think [back] to some of the most polished guys we've had
Andrew Luck was awfully polished a Few years back. I think Davis is right there
He not been is just like injury love it
It's like freaky. [I] think that Davis mills high school highlight. Tape is the best highlight. Tape that I've evaluated
It's really nothing that jumps out that he can't do
[what] we look at when we evaluate base balance load being able to control the ball being on the plane conflict
Disassociating your upper and lower half he checks the box on everything and when I'm watching his film
I [catalogue] probably over [10] throws that or [elite-level] throws
You're saying this kid did [not] only control the ball you can control mighty controlled environment
And he's gonna be a big-time player at Stanford. [here's] one for you three people better alive
You can pick the brain on anything you want because [I] can today tonight. Oh
probably Martin Luther King
George Washington
And Kanye [west] honey west yeah, obviously it's different. It's different. Yeah, what do you ask?
Does some of the decisions he is and like how public he is with everything? Yeah, just how he deals with all the
Critics and stuff you just fill in the blanks that you value as quarterback traits and he has them
But I think bigger than that. He's got a super quiet line and then the noise never gets, too
Loud the pressure never gets too [intense] [I] think he cares as much as anybody
I think life is bigger than this position
If I throw an interception, I'm I'm fine if I throw a touchdown, I'm not gonna celebrate and go crazy
It's just fun [to] [be] out there and keep a calm head and be the man for your team. His size his frame
I mean just prototypical and I felt first-round draft pick
He's my number one, and if I had to start [the] program he would be my guy
you